aber das is the world so einer weiteren
video korrekt herzlich willkommen hier
zudem world service game freunde jeder
youtuber das spiel wahrscheinlich schon
mal gezockt was jeder youtuber jeder
mensch jeder jedes lebewesen sogar oro
ich habe die gerade an neben eine
euro-krise ukulele ist ein gegenstand
dem ich liebe ja keine ahnung aber es
ist auf jeden fall ein spiel denke ich
wenn ihr das seht es hat nahezu jeder
schon mal irgendwie gezockt und gefangen
natürlich hier direkt an mit dem game
wir sehen hier am ohr games
die world heart is geld so freunde wir
klicken natürlich direkt auf play game
und jura der adscale die blues tag ist
ein chor ist mir scheißegal einfach
plan.net okay ich denke das hat jeder
schon mal gezockt dieses med das kann
nicht sein
der grüne bereich links ist mein anfangs
bereich der bereich rechts ist mein end
bereich roboter ich habe eine taktik ich
muss so oro ausrutscher des hotels
organisiert es ruckelt es lädt das
spielt sich doch war schon okay
das sieht recht simpel aus orderten
shops hey ich muss doch einfach nur eine
logische wieder scheiße was ist denn los
mit dem spiel
die taste weg
jetzt sollte wieder flüssig so freunde
jetzt heißes ding neben ich weiß nicht
muss ich dieses gelbe ding da bekommen
das ist nicht wahr
suche ich das denn so jetzt geht's
wieder so jetzt hier eben schnell die
scheiße nach hause holen hier so freunde
ich scheiß auf diesen gelben punkt an
damit ich will jetzt einfach hier den
sieg holen ganz gediegen heben durch
einfach so hier lang
als letzter wieder und jetzt abziehen
scheiße ich brauchte gelben punkt alter
das stand doch sogar in der blöden
anfangs einleitung collect die galloways
wie scheiß bin ich denn wo das squaire
ich glaub an dich du bist ja mein
mehrheit
juli
doch freunde jetzt hier mich amüsiert
mich jetzt hier gut dass mich kann jetzt
hier nichts aufhalten nicht gelang hier
lang hier lang hier lang hier lang hier
lang erzielen
hierhin schnell freunde es dieses spiel
es rüttelt diese vom bruder ich habe den
plan
ich gehe einfach schon vorher hier ein
bisschen mehr auf die höhe jetzt schnell
jetzt aber ziel vielleicht nicht doch
einfach an dem level jetzt keine
garantie wenn man die ganze zeit
den roten renner mit guckt kriegt man
echt nach halbzeit wirklich wieder
augenkrebs er diese wirklich solche
spiele okay es wird auf jeden fall schon
mal wieder ein bisschen normaler ich
weiß freunde das spiel kinder zu jeder
und jeder hat irgendwie schon mal
gezockt und ich habe es auch selbst
wahrscheinlich schon mal gezockt aber
chance aber das ist schon so lange her
dass ich mich an die level gar nicht
mehr erinnern kann
das ist nicht wahr nein mach jetzt hier
kommt schnell
ich habe plan nein jetzt aber hier kommt
jetzt hier zeigt in lockerer freunde des
bca
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein hier
blöder das kann ich so schwer sei dieser
blöden nein diese nein
okay das ruhig ich habe zum plan
ok ich glaube ich muss von innen mehr
nach außen gehen wieder so
ich habe alles spaß von alkohol ist
nicht gut wenn die flasche fast auf dem
sprung remember the objective ist
gebiete game wird sie liest am mount ob
des festes teil
ach ja stimmt stimmt ich muss mir zeit
lassen einfach ich musste dieses weiße
kästchen ich komme aber nicht mal hin es
ruckelt schon wieder sowie saubere ich
weiß jetzt amstetten nein nein nein nein
irgendwann später okay dann gehe ich
jetzt erst ins weiße und jetzt muss ich
hin muss jetzt sind in das dass die safe
sein okay selbst der nächste ist freunde
ab in die safe mit nächste level
ist hier völlig um drucker ich will
nicht ich will nicht in der station
wieder gespannt 8 checkpoints geholt
geile affen gekürzte kaká
jetzt hin scheiße und jetzt hier
oh mein gott freund ich bin so nah form
vom ende an spannung pur und jetzt
freunde okay hier oben ist ja noch recht
idee da kann ich ja einfach hier so hier
oben ist ja noch recht liegen hier oben
bleib ruhig oder square wo es richtig
weh da kann ich ja eben schnell einfach
hier durch beschluss nein ich kenne
erstmal hier kurz diesem chip sagt und
jetzt jetzt ekelhaft freunde vor allem
rücke das so scheiße wie sauer alter das
ist doch echt nicht wahr
das kann nicht sein
dem stellt die kkm 100 zurück und jetzt
die rolle
und wenn ich nicht aufnehmen könnte es
gar nicht also es liegt nicht an der
grafik sondern einfach ein flashback um
ehrlich zu sein möchte ich euch das
nicht mehr und es läuft flüssig und den
chip so und jetzt ab hierdurch wurde den
chip bruder und jetzt hab hier nein
die chip ist am start und jetzt hab hier
durch nein ich gebe auf ich gebe auf ich
nehme das das von mir aus also ein
linkes in der beschreibung konnte er
gerne zocken geht ihr keiner bis zum
ende bringen ohne tausendmal zu sterben
oder irgendwo in der 62 gestorben
ich kriege es einfach nicht rein das was
für ruckelt das ist ja so richtig
komisch gucke ich drücke ich drücke
jetzt die taste und jetzt geht er jetzt
drücke jetzt die taste hört mal genau
wenn ich die taste drücke aber jetzt
geht's jetzt gehts aber es ist halt
schon immer so ein bisschen ruckeln das
ist halt ein bisschen scheiße ich weiß
nicht woran es liegt aber das war auf
jeden fall das video freut ich dachte an
einem samstag mache ich so ein video
wenn ihr andere geile spiele kennt das
wurde mir sehr oft vorgeschlagen
übrigens world service game sagt das
noch mal wenn ihr andere spiele kennt so
in die kategorien die klasse so geile
indie game zu
bescheuerte spiele habe ich da bock
drauf dann schreibt man die gerne und in
die kommentare ich würde meine bewertung
freund wünscht wunderschönen samstag und
tschüss